these are finally getting through to the
people completely cut off and the
International Community is responding
where is the lack of Aid coming from is
the government not doing enough
no that the situation this unprecedented
Monsoon rains it never happened in the
last 30 years this amount of the rains
and the moon to spell was prolonged so
even if there were some preparedness or
some disaster management Frameworks of
the government these rains this
situation is unprecedented it's bigger
like just one third of the Pakistan is
in a nail in the need of humanitarian
Aid it's affected by the flood it's 4.2
million it's almost like uh area of
United Kingdom that is 118 districts are
destroyed 35 million people are impacted
by this uh this situation so the
disaster is Mega it's a huge so uh and
then you know this disaster has started
in the beginning of August end of July
but media just took it took the
attention quite recently so when media
took the attention and government of
Pakistan the appeal then I I could see
some Panic some sense of urgency and now
I mean the situation has almost out of
control so you need a lot of resources
very quickly there is no issue that the
the capacity on the ground the
organizations the government can deliver
but the problem is the resources like
Islamic Leaf launched a appeal of 15
million in beginning of August and now
with this situation we we increased it
to 30 million and we are aiming to reach
to half of the million for response and
recovery but so far our appeal is just
25 percent funded so that's the
situation the main problem is the
funding so the government's the donor
governments they just started announcing
some of the some of the assistance but
uh when it will reach and whether is it
enough or not because it's the is the
loss of billion dollars in
infrastructure people houses people
livelihoods it's an impact on the lives
of the poor people the areas which are
affected they are also hit by the
climate change phenomena like in April
there was a drought in these areas where
we were responding to the drought and in
July it's the mega flood unprecedented
disaster there obviously okay you heard
it from Asik shirazi from the aid agency
Islamic relief thank you very much for
filling Us in on the catastrophic
situation there in Pakistan